so this is a continuation of Leslie's
talk Leslie talked about kind of the
fundamentals of approximate counting and
what goes on and I'm going to talk about
applying all of that stuff to constraint
satisfaction problems one of the reasons
we're interested in constraint
satisfaction problems is that basically
they're a broad class of problems that
naturally encode all kinds of useful and
interesting problems but at the same
time they're not so broad that we can't
come up with decent classifications of
what's going on okay and I guess this is
kind of the first time I've been to a
boot camp I was led to believe they
involve much more shouting and push-ups
than this but this one seems to be a
very civilized kind of a boot camp okay
so this is just a bit of revision from
Leslie's talk so the notion of
approximate counting that we are going
to be interested in is the fully
polynomial time randomized approximation
scheme so that is a randomized algorithm
from a function which takes on kind of a
string as an input so as you have some
instance of some problem two real
numbers and for the time being I'm not
going to really worry about what kind of
numbers the input to this algorithm is
going to be an instance of the problem
that we want to solve the thing that we
want to count and an error tolerance
epsilon and we're going to try to output
a value such that with probability at
least three quarters were pretty close
to the real answer to the problem okay
so pretty close means within each of the
plus and minus epsilon multiplicatively
this bigger three quarters is the
standard figure that always gets used
you might be worried that that's not a
very high probability but we can always
just do it again and again and again and
take the media and or something like
that so the specific value of three
quarters isn't very important will get
the same notion of approximation more or
less whatever fracture
use that and the requirement is for the
polynomial time part of this is that our
algorithm is going to run in polynomial
time in the size of the instance and
also polynomial in one over epsilon so
if you want a more accurate answer I'm
allowed to spend a little bit longer
giving it to you and the notion of would
you yes actually deterministically
polynomial it's not her it's not a in
expectation yeah um okay and the notion
of reducibility that will use between
problems is AP reducibility Leslie gave
a brief hint at the definition of that
in her talk I'm going to give an even
briefer hint basically the point of APU
reducibility is that if you've got an F
price for a function f and f is AP
reducible to G arm all the way round oh
sorry i always get reductions the wrong
way around G is AP reducible to F then I
can use the F prize for F to give an eff
France 4G ok and that's as much detail
as we're going to need in this talk ok I
also need to set up constraint
satisfaction problems for you so
constraint satisfaction problems Ron as
follows we're going to have a bunch of
variables we want to assign values to
those variables in a way that satisfy a
bunch of constraints that we think yet
so the values that we're going to are
assigned to those variables come from a
finite domain D which work in a treat is
fixed a constraint looks like this it
specifies one of the relations in the
constraint language and a set of
variables that are going to be
constrained by that relation
so an assignment of values from the
domain to the variables is a satisfying
assignment if for every constraint of
this form the values that we assigned to
these variables x 1 up to X K our values
that give you a tuple in this relation R
okay so you can think of are as being a
list of values that these variables X 1
or 2 out k are allowed to take together
in combination and the counting
constraint satisfaction problem for a
constraint language gamma is I give you
an instance so a set of variables and a
bunch of constraints where all of the
relations in those constraints are
relations in gamma and we ask how many
different satisfying assignments other
and it's important to note that we treat
gamma the constraint language here as
being a parameter to the problem okay so
we'll fix gamma and then we'll ask about
the complexity of counting assignments
to instances of CSP camera
okay so for an example 3sat is a
constraint satisfaction problem so you
could probably figured that out from the
informal definition where I just said
well we have a bunch of variables sure
3sat has a bunch of variables we've got
to assign values of those variables sure
three snap they're called true and false
the constraints in 3sat are expressed as
logical clauses so we just need to
translate those clauses into relations
so I'm going to use 0 for false and one
for true as usual we can have up to
permutations for different kinds of
clauses in a 3sat instance either all of
the literals in the claws are positive
all those 1 negative 2 or 3 negative
ones now to satisfy a course like this
where every variable appears positively
well any assignment will do except one
the assignment that makes everything
falls so the relation that corresponds
to this clause is the relation that has
every possible assignment to the three
variables except for the one that makes
everything false which fails to satisfy
that course and similarly for the other
ones if we've got one negated variable
well the only assignment that fails to
satisfy that is the one where that
variable is true and the other two are
false now and the same for the other
ones okay so you might think this is a
little bit of bad news in the we already
know that so we're interested in
approximately counting solutions to
constraint satisfaction problems but now
that we found out that three saboteur is
a CSP we know that certainly there are
some CSPs we're counting those counting
the number of solutions is going to be
hard okay
because we know we can't approximately
approximately count solutions to sat
instances unless probably unlikely
things happen in complexity theory so
unless NP is RP and actually that's
going to be a general theme for this
talk a lot of the results in this talk
rather than being about things that you
can approximate are going to be about
things that you can't approximate or as
an intermediate level things that we
don't know how to approximate okay just
going to move to the side of her a
little bit and give an alternative view
of constraint satisfaction problems you
can treat an instance of a constraint
satisfaction problem and also the
constraint language as being relational
structures okay the constraint language
just is a relational structure it's a
domain and a set of relations over that
domain you can view the instances of
relational structure by treating the
variables as the domain of that
structure and the constraints as
defining the relations so whenever you
have a constraint apply to some
variables then that you + variables is
in the corresponding relation now in
this world view a satisfying assignment
is just a homomorphism from the
structure that represents your instance
to the structure that represents your
constraint language it's just an
assignment of values of the first domain
the variables to values of the second
domain the domain of the constraint
language that preserves the relations
whenever some whenever a bunch of
variables are constrained they must be
mapped to something that satisfies that
ok so we can see these problems as
homomorphism problems so that also tells
you that any problem that is for example
a homomorphism problem of graphs is a
special case of the constraint
satisfaction problem the reason I'm
going in this direction is that
polymorphisms compose so if I've got a
homomorphism from an instance I one to
an instance I two and if that instance I
two is satisfiable which means there's a
homomorphism from I two on two gamma but
I 1 and I too must both be yes instances
of the constraint satisfaction problem
you can use the homomorphism from
compose these two homomorphisms you get
a homomorphism from I 12 gamma and that
is exactly a satisfying assignment for I
one so that for example tells us that
hamiltonicity can't be a constraint
satisfaction problem okay because we can
perfectly well have whatever graph this
gamma is that we choose as our
constraint language we can perfectly
well have a non Hamiltonian graph which
has a homomorphism into a Hamiltonian
graph which has a homomorphism into
gamma okay so that gives us an example
of something that isn't a constraint
satisfaction problem which might at
first sound like it's a bad thing don't
you want to be able to do everything but
actually turns out of being able to do
everything would be a bad thing as
Leslie told
the other day which I guess was
yesterday if number P and P are
different there must be these infinite
hierarchies between the two so that
applies even to approximation not just
to exact count but if we've got these
infinite hierarchies then we can't
expect to have nice classifications of
problems because we'd have to have
infinitely many different levels in our
classification so the hope is that
because csps aren't actually the whole
of number P that maybe we can actually
still
so the hope is that since csps aren't
the whole of Numb poppy maybe we'll get
lucky and these infinite and we'll avoid
these infinite hierarchies and maybe we
can get some nice classifications that
in fact we can okay so I'm not going to
steal she chants thunder so I will state
this there and very vaguely because I
believe she's going to talk about it
later but for any fixed constraint
language gamma if you're interested in
exactly counting the number of
satisfying assignments to gamma there
are two options either you can do that
in polynomial time all the problems
number p complete that depends only on
the structure of gamma and every gamma
falls into one of these two classes I'm
not going to give you any more details
but will come later I see you
okay so instead we're going to talk
about approximate captain
so I gave you an example of number three
set which was an example where the
domain had just two elements so for the
time being and actually for most of the
talk I'm going to concentrate on two
element domains and on fighting with
passing trucks okay so if we restrict
our attention to two element domains
then we have the following now as as we
had last time it turns out not to be a
dichotomy probably but there are three
possibilities so depending on the
structure of the relations in the
constraint language the complexity of
approximating the number of satisfying
assignments to an instance can have one
of three one of three values it's either
doable exactly as it happens in
polynomial time or its equivalent to
counting independent sets in bipartite
graphs which is this central problem in
approximate counting that seems to come
up everywhere alternatively it's as hard
as it can get it's a pee into reducible
with counting satisfying assignments to
sat instances okay so what are the
criteria for this so a relation is a
fine if it's just a set of solutions to
a bunch of linear equations over the two
element field okay if you have a set of
such of relations that are just
solutions to linear equations it turns
out that you can use something like gas
in an elimination and you can count
exactly the number of solutions to a set
of equations in polynomial time
the other two cases are a little bit
more complicated so if all of the
relations that you're given in your
constraint language can be defined by a
conjunction of predicates on your
variables where each predicate is either
this variable has value zero this
variable has value 1 or its boolean
implication between those two variables
if you can define all of your relations
in your constraint language using a
logical formula of that kind then
approximately counting satisfying
assignments to your instance to any
instance of that constraint language is
AP and true reducible with counting
independent sets otherwise so if you
can't define it using implication and
pincers their own pens to one then we're
equivalent to sat okay so I'm going to
go through some of the proof of this
so first of all I'm going to show that
we can reduce counting independent sets
in bipartite graphs to a constraint
satisfaction instance where the only
relation that we use is boolean
implication okay so i'm going to write
em for the relation that is those
boolean values that imply each other
okay so we've been given some kind of a
graph we've got vertices on the left
we've got vertices on the right and
we've got some collection of edges
between them we want to know how many
independent sets that are in this graph
okay so the key point about this
application relation is that there's
exactly one thing that it pivots okay if
I relate x and y with implication they
can take any values except X can't be
one with y0
which is kind of like what happens with
independent sets okay if I want to
decide whether two vertices say this one
and this one are in or out of the
independent set well I can make any any
choice I want except for one the choice
where they're both in okay so if we take
this graph and rewrite it as a
constraint satisfaction instance by
putting an implication constraint from
left to right on slowly as a serving are
just disappear off screen just appeared
on the screen oh I see why that is that
part okay um replace each edge with a
directed implication constraint now this
can be satisfied in any way except for
the way that puts a one on this side and
a zero on this side so n variable on the
left of my constraint satisfaction
instance that is a witch way around
alert a one way around yes a variable
that gets assigned a one on the left is
something that's in the independent set
anything that is assigned a zero on the
right is in the independent set we
forbidden an edge between two things
that are in so there's a one-to-one
correspondence between satisfying
assignments to the constraint
satisfaction problem and independent
sets in the graph
okay so that's one direction to go in
the other direction I'm going to show
that for every constraint satisfaction
instance where our constraints are just
this relation for boolean implication
and the constraints that say this value
variable has value zero or value one
that we can reduce this to this
ok
so we've got some kind of instance
with a set of variables and
some kind of set of constraints between
them so i put a directed edge to mean
so there's a constraint that X implies Y
ok
all of these implications actually
impose a partial order on the values
that the variables can take okay so for
example if this vertex if this variable
is assigned one then in a satisfying
assignment it implies this one so this
one must also be one and this one and
this one and this one this one on the
other hand could be either 0 or 1
there are a couple of other things that
can happen let me add an edge back there
it could be that we have cycles in our
implication graph so now we're not
defining a partial order anymore well
that's okay because if X implies Y and Y
implies that uncertain plies X but in
fact the value taken by these three
variables must be equal so I can merge
them all into a single variable and
restore my partial order another thing
that we'd have to look at is that we
might have some of these constraints
let's say that a particular variable has
value zero or that it has value want
well that's okay
if I can strain this variable here to
have value one well we can just
propagate that constraint through the
graph and we'll find that some other
collection of variables have value one
and we can delete all of those because
in any satisfying assignment we already
know what happens to them elderslie if
for example this variable must be equal
to zero while this variable is implied
by this one so this one must be zero as
well and so must everything above it so
again we can process the graph to remove
all of the constraints that say that a
value variable must be equal to zero by
the time we've done that we'll we will
end up with a partial order and now
satisfying assignments correspond to
down sets within that partial order and
we already know that counting down sets
in a partial order is exactly equivalent
to counting independent sets in a
bipartite graph approximate okay so that
establishes the reduction map
now I'm cheating I'm afraid because what
I told you back here is not that every
relation is one of these three things
which is what I proved on the following
slide or the previous slide which our
way around you're thinking about it I
said it's defined by a conjunction of
them so that's not quite enough I've
argued that if I have exactly those
three predicates climb equivalent to
this okay so in particular our
constraint language can contain all
kinds of constraints all kinds of
relations defined from those three
predators but maybe it just doesn't
include m-maybe we were unlucky okay if
we don't have em given to us as a
relation in our constraint language what
we need to do is somehow make it okay so
we'll make it using gadgets and I will
show you how to do that okay
we might also need to make these two
guys so I'll give you a brief hint about
how to do that suppose one of your
relations in your constraint language
contains the position and we may as well
say the first one where which way around
am I going
in the majority of places we've got a
zero okay so say in the first position
some relation has more zeroes than ones
ok
so if we had a whole bunch of
constraints so if we call this relation
R
we're going to add a whole bunch of
constraints where the first variable is
X and all of these remaining variables
are completely fresh variables so this
will be one set of variables this will
be more new variables add lots more if
we have many of these constraints then I
just realized I said one thing and did
the opposite
the majority of these assignments will
be assignment where this variable takes
value zero it looks like five better bid
you adieu sixty percent of them of each
of the assignments to this constraint
will have X equal to 0 as I have more
and more and more of those constraints
the proportion of assignments that said
x 20 will get closer and closer to 1 so
approximately which is good enough I
will be forcing the value X to have
value 0 in the vast majority of
satisfying assignments it will do and
the other ones will be negligible up to
that little factor of e to the e to the
plus or minus epsilon that unload from
the approximation okay and it turns out
that if our relation is defined from
implications and pins to 0 and 1 and if
it's not a fine actually there always
will be a relation that's dominated by
zeros in some position and also there'll
be a relation is dominated by once in
some position so i am going to be able
to make these okay let's get rid of that
cycle again
it's an implication we use a similar
argument to what we used before so we
take our relation that is defined using
implications and zeros and ones we
scrunch up any cycles because they mean
that the variables have to be equal and
we're going to end up again with some
kind of a tree well again if i take this
tree i say that this one is zero which i
can do because I've managed to simulate
this constraint and let's say this one
all of those are zero now this one edge
hanging off here well this can be 0 or 1
this can be 0 or 1 they have to imply
each other so I've built a gadget which
on these two variables gives me
implication okay
now it turns out that any relation which
was not defined only for implications
and zeros and ones you can build either
or or NAND using similar kinds of
techniques the point about Orrin and is
that well we're interested in 3sat
instances through sat instances are made
exactly from ores combined with ok the
and you get from the fact that you have
multiple constraints that are all
essentially handed together nand is just
the same thing that we've flipped the
role of their own one so if you can
solve man you can solve or okay so that
gives us our approximation trichotomy
for boolean CSP if our relations are all
I fine we can use Gaussian elimination
solvent ends exactly in polynomial time
if our relations are conjunctions of
equals 0 equals 1 and implications then
we can extract implication from that
which gives us exactly this and
otherwise we can get NAND or and where
as hard as sad
okay so now let's generalize a bit and
instead of having relational constraints
let's have waited constraints so instead
of having our constraint language be a
collection of relations over the domain
they're now going to be functions from
from the domain to let's say the
non-negative real numbers there are some
issues with exactly what kind of real
numbers you allow so really this should
be something like the rationals or the
algebraic numbers but the low-level
details of that don't particularly Matt
okay so our instances look exactly the
same as they did before except now we
have functions rather than relations and
our goal is to compute the partition
function which I suspect that everyone
in the room knows what a partition
function is by now is anyone willing to
catch my eye and tell me that they don't
okay so i won't bother defining the
partition function just the product of
the values taken by the function summed
over although i just defined it the
unweighted case just corresponds to
functions where you restrict the domain
of the function to be sorry the range of
the function to be 0 1 so 0 corresponds
to a tuple that isn't in the relation
and that turns this whole product to 0 1
corresponds to a tuple that is in the
relation
okay and as an example the usual running
example so the easing model with no
external field is just the constraint
satisfaction problem the weighted
constraint satisfaction problem with a
single function which is the easing
function okay so if you give the two
constraint variables the same weight
sorry the same spin then they pick up
wait lambda and if you give them
different spins they pick up Wade one we
can also introduce external fields if we
add some uri functions to our constraint
language now the reason I've said that
these are mixed external fields is not
just because you could have multiple
different unary weights corresponding to
a different field at each vertex but
also the kind of annoying technical
reasons even if you only have one weight
function if you want to have easing with
an external field you're supposed to
apply that feel to every vertex in the
same way there's nothing in the rules of
constraint satisfaction that says that
every vertex every variable must have
exactly one unity constraint and it must
always be the same one so for example
even if you have a single external field
then there are instances of CSP where
you don't apply that field to any of
your variables and there are instances
where you apply the field 27 times to
one variable which has a diff which
effectively gives it a different field
to applying that constraint 26 times to
that one variable so if you wanted to
enforce a uniform external field across
all of your variables that corresponds
to a restriction on the instances that
you're allowed to the CSP so we're not
going to go that down that road
ok so again to advertise a forthcoming
talk a lot is known about the complexity
of exactly calculating these partition
functions seriously a very very lot i
defined the weights to be weights to
non-negative real numbers in fact we now
know dichotomies for CSP out to complex
valued weights which is some seriously
impressive stuff okay
I'm going to talk about approximation
still so I'm not going to go down the
road exact counting as we saw in even
the boolean case of unweighted CSP the
complexity depends very much on what
functions you can express using the
functions that you're given in your
constraint language so for our
unweighted CSP it was all about can i
define the implication relation in which
case I'm going to be equivalent to BES
or I'm going to be at least as hard as
this can i define horn and in which case
I'm going to be equivalent design okay
so in the world of weighted CSP we're
interested in what functions we can
define from the functions were given and
the way we look at that is through
functional clothes so a clone is
basically a set of functions that is
closed under some operations and those
operations correspond to define ability
so for example if I have two functions F
and G and I apply them to the same pair
of variables x and y I'm essentially
defining a new function which is the
product of the values taken by F and G
that comes about just because of the way
the partition function is defined the
thing that we calculate is products of
constraints
if I have a constraint on variables say
X and said where Z doesn't appear in any
other constraints I can kind of consider
that as being a function just on sir on
X if we just focus our attention on eggs
and the function that we get is well
from one term of the partition function
will pick up the value that F takes when
Zed has that value and then for the next
value that said could take will pick up
one of those as well they all get added
together so the result is that we're
essentially defining a function that
just sums out that variable also just
it's kind of a little bit of bookkeeping
if I give you a binary constraint and
you can also if you like imagine the
bats say a ternary constraint that just
doesn't constrain one of the variables
so we cannot define functions of higher
arity and this one which might look a
bit odd how on earth are you going to
define limits in a constraint
satisfaction problem well it corresponds
more to the reductions between instances
than to the instances themselves for
example here what I did was I took
essentially a sequence of instances
where I add more and more and more of
these constraints with the goal of
getting sufficiently close to forcing a
particular feature of my solutions that
the nice way to analyze that is in terms
of limits which is exactly the concert
to something getting sufficiently close
okay so clone is just a set of functions
closed under all of these operations a
particular class of functions that we're
going to be interested in are the log
super modular functions okay so these
are functions from boolean functions
where for any potential arguments accent
why we have this equation holding so the
value of the function at X or Y times x
and y is at least as big as the value at
x times the value of y if our function
takes no arguments at all so it's just a
constant then this is trivial right
because all four terms of the thing or
equal if our function only takes one
argument then again it's trivial if
these are 0 & 1 then these two are 0 & 1
and if these are both the same then
these are both the same so any knowledge
or urinary function is going to be logs
with modular but lots of interesting
functions to log super modular to our
good friend implication so and this is
proof by example you'd have to do need
to look at all of the possibilities but
this is the really the only interesting
one if I take my two inputs X is zero
one and then why is 10 well if you do
the arithmetic you get the left hand
side is 1 implies 1 and 0 implies 0 both
of which are true the right hand side is
this term comes out at one but this term
is 0 because one does not imply 0 okay
so that's an example of a log super
modular function
another example is ferromagnetic eating
again proof by the same choice of x and
y these are the both equal pairs so we
pick up a lambda squared and these two
are both these terms are both one on the
other hand antiferromagnetism one
because lambda is greater than one on
the other hand if we take anti
ferromagnetic easy then lambda is less
than one so anti Pharaoh easing is not a
lots of modular function
okay so at the moment I'll explain why
we care about these functions first I'm
just going to build up some more things
about these sets of inter definable
functions if you like okay so I'm just
going to put angle brackets around a set
of functions to define the least clone
containing that set of functions so that
is just the closure of the functions in
F under our operations for define
ability and remember our operations for
define ability correspond to how you
would build a gadget okay we call a coin
conservative if it contains all possible
unary functions okay so all functions
from your domain to the non-negative
real numbers and conservative clones are
going to pay a very important part in
what comes up partly because they're
there the clones we really understand a
couple of things about clones it turns
out that if you have a function which
you can't define just using dis equality
and URI weights then you can define the
implication function using that function
okay that's kind of similar arguments to
what we did earlier and another useful
fact is that if you have a function
that's not log super modular then
actually you can define all possible
functions using just that one function
using the clone operations that we gave
okay so where do these ideas get used so
I've described this as an approximate
theorem about approximation because the
phrasing here is is rather loose but I
wanted to show you it in this version
first because this is kind of the kernel
of truth and this is the one that you
would understand and if I show you the
real version which I will do in a minute
if I showed you that first you well you
wouldn't run screaming out of the room
but you do at least look away okay so
take any conservative constraint
language so that means we've got all
unary functions available to us to use
in instances if the functions in there
can be defined using only dis equality
in unary weights so again this is very
similar to being a set of affine
functions but with weights added then we
can approximately count the number of
satisfying assignments if we can't then
approximately counting satisfying
assignments is at least as hard as
counting independent sets in the
bipartite graph and if not only that but
we've got a function that isn't even
logged super modular in there then
because we can use gadgets to define any
function we want in particular we can
define functions that let us count
satisfying assignments at instances okay
why have I said this is an approximate
theorem well if you remember way back in
the day when i define constraint
satisfaction to you I said this thing
was finite and this thing is not finite
this thing contains all possible
functions from the domain to the real
numbers and there are quite a lot of
those and it certainly isn't a finite
number ok so the slight hack around to
be a little bit more formal is to talk
about finite subsets of those constraint
languages
okay so what's really going on is that
if you're constraint language is defined
from disa calls you need weights then
whatever finite subset of it you pick we
can approximately count solutions to
that constraint satisfaction problem
otherwise there's going to be a finite
sub language at least one finite sub
language for which counting satisfying
assignments this as hard as biss and
again if there's some non lsm function
in there then there's at least one
finite sub language for which counting
and satisfying assignments is as hard as
sir because I say at least one point
night that must be infinitely many
finite ones as well with us
okay all of that was for the boolean
domain so I'm only assigning 0 & 1 to my
variables why do I talk about that well
partly because it's slightly easier and
second because actually it already
contains almost everything that we have
so far if we allow arbitrary finite
domains for our weighted constraint
languages it turns out that the
complexity of approximate counting
depends very much on firstly what binary
functions you can define well that
shouldn't be surprising because we've
already seen that it often depends on
things like being able to define binary
implication or binary or or land and
also even though we've got this huge
domain the classification only actually
depends on how these binary functions
depend on two element subsets of our
domain so essentially the complexity
depends on the whole bunch of bio of
boolean problems that are hiding inside
your larger domain okay
so the corresponding property to log
super modularity is weak log super
modularity okay why is it week well
firstly we only care about binary
functions so a constraint language is
weakly submodular if all of the binary
functions you can describe you can
define with it have this property the
property is that essentially the is the
property of log super modularity where
you have and said well I picking two
elements of my domain I'll call one of
them 0 and one of them one and I'll ask
if that if the resulting function is
logs it modular but we weaken it further
by saying that actually this inequality
doesn't have to hold all the time on the
other hand if it fails it fails in a
fairly tame way it can only either it's
true or it's false for the reason that
the left hand side is Sarah
ok
maybe I should have given you that the
simplified version of this one as well
but here we go so weak lots of
modularity is going to correspond to our
middle case I haven't defined what week
longer modularity is but the super
refers to greater than or equal to so
weak log modularity is that this is an
equality or it fails because this side
is 0 or it fails because the other side
is 0 so for weekly log modulo which
again is quite a lot like being some
kind of affine function or at least the
functions look a fine when you crunch
them down to two element domains then we
can exactly count the solutions in
polynomial time on the other hand if we
are weakly log super modular um which
way around does that then 40 okay then
we can essentially reduce the problem to
counting
counting satisfying assignments two
instances where all of the functions are
actually log super modular functions on
two element domains and also it's as
hard as this for at least some choice of
the unary functions otherwise we can
code up sat and everything is as hard as
it can be okay so I talked about boolean
and with unweighted boolean CSP we were
able to make all of the unary functions
that we needed as soon as we moved on
from to weighted CSP we've always had
this assumption tagging along with us
that we've that we're given as many
unary functions as we want in our
constraint language okay why do we do
that well firstly those unary functions
are really really useful we use them
although all over the place in
reductions and it seems to be very hard
to work without a supply of free unary
functions we don't particularly well I
how do i phrase this to avoid in
something anyone our understanding of
non conservative club and cyclones that
don't have all these unary functions
available is not as good as our
understanding of the conservative clones
and the structure of all of the
definable functions within them and yeah
it is a a current area of research is to
try and get rid of this conservative ax
t assumption and try to try to actually
classify general onward general weighted
constraint satisfaction problems without
needing the assistance of all your
functions
okay thank you you say something about
the gaps in your previous slide but so
you've got some open problems here but I
guess they're so just I'm lurking there
as well there are some looking here as
well we don't know if these two cases
are really the same this one feels a lot
like saying that you can solve it using
this this one says that you can solve
this with it but we're not at all sure
it would be nice if for example these
web s equivalent
this still allows further
classes yes yeah but there could
potentially be be stuffed between here
so sorry so the question was in this
setup it seems that we only care about
binary functions on two elements of
domains whereas in Holland junior says
that there are cases where actually need
to look at three element domains to get
the true behavior and I'm not aware of
any where where we think that higher
higher size domains would be needed do
you know any this is only conservative
right true true yeah
ok so we'll resume at three o'clock then
thanks